e aí galera que se ronaldo vocês olha só
que eles estamos aqui agora em que eu
tomar esse vídeo aqui assim sem dancinha
no começo em nada o que foi que
aconteceu quando completou 20 milhões
nem eu devo pensando aqui ea galera fala
assim cae do senado que a 20 milhões o
executivo camarário realmente 20 bilhões
são 20 milhões que é muita gente e é
inexplicável e crescimento que cresce no
mundo
a que se deve esse crescimento toda a
que se deve isso tudo a mim porque eu
faço vídeos muito bom e cadeirinha isso
é só comédia em um morro se dava a vocês
porque olha querendo ou não eu faço os
vídeos é o bota na internet mas são
vocês que que assista o vídeo fosse
encarar não é que vídeo massa mostra pra
fulano que as pessoas falam que eu sou
seu fã minha mãe é sou fã meu filho é
seu fã
a minha avó és o fã eu falei meu deus
avó ela nem share gaga e ela é minha fã
tudo isso todo esse crescimento a vocês
então o que acontece é uma idéia que eu
tive eu vou fazer show agora em julho
nos estados unidos da américa othon fix
the rise of london pipa ou só falar eu
vou fazer show no dia 3 de julho em
boston nos estados unidos lá no bbb e
vans então vou fazer show no dia 14 de
julho em orlando nos estados unidos bob
carter
o fetran observar o dia 15 de julho vai
ser em miami no olímpia ter x 0 que ia
levar um fã cara olha que esse massa
levar um fora assistir nos estados
unidos que tope autografando esse vídeo
eu vou ligar para a mulher saber se vai
dar certo e tomara que dê um ano atrás
nem quando nem falar da [ __ ] gastando os
créditos oi oi também inglês falou tudo
observa que em casa eu tô eu queria eu
pensei na idéia de levar a idéia a gente
vai fazer um show lá é nos estados
unidos agora no próximo mês né
eu to de papai também só que eu tenho
idéia assim o canal fez 20 milhões né 20
milhões
obrigado estou esse dinheiro
é o chão para frente aí eu estava
pensando aqui
assim eu pra mim é pensando comigo não
sei se você vai se você vai querer mas
assim o positio milhões são o povo né a
galera eu sei que é caro eu sei como é
que é é uma portaria essas coisas mas eu
queria saber o seguinte será que não dá
pra gente levar um fã para assisti lá
nos estados unidos
aí no estado isso que elas são na
verdade assim sempre ri união agora juro
sem soar com o time da costa brasil e
winter som militar e as 20 melhores um
canal ele que é trazer o onça do brasil
o pecado e assistir a um show dele acha
que consegue mais mas assim a pessoa a
pessoa é bom e fui conhecer mais sozinho
acho que será que não dava um
acompanhante
tem gente pode fazer um sorteio será um
negócio um concurso cultural e se há
alguma coisa na página da abelha
aí eu boto eu eu voto eles
em cima de uma foto de aceitar uma mesa
com eles em reunião então você conseguiu
sozinho então não faz assim vocês vocês
bola tão fácil assim vocês bola promoção
aí e aí me manda que o que eu falo aqui
no vídeo como é que é
dizem que é tudo vai rolando vai não vai
à montanha russa não vai nas coisas em
que não há gente muito feliz de trazer
você pra cá eu estou muito feliz com seu
de com seus 20 milhões a gente admira
muito o seu trabalho e eu tenho certeza
que isso
assim apesar de serem visitados não
seria possível sem seu público então se
eu tenho a roque da costa brasil ápis
também tem e vamos fazer isso pra você
tá tá bem então então bola e me manda
aqui na tap que eu terminar de gravar um
vídeo para poder embalar a galera como é
que é seu marido tem a mesma coisa assim
é em cima da hora tem que seguir
valeu támbém foi de pechora também
obrigado
então é isso aí vovó para eles ao ver
que ela vai fazer porque eu pensei assim
cara eu é assim eu eu poderia escolher
mas é não sei vou pegar vou apontar
pessoa vou escolher ok eu vou gravar um
vídeo aqui pra eles vão apostar no
instagram da biz que é o que a empresa
que está me levando para lá os estados
unidos ea ir lá nesse vídeo no instagram
dhabi que vou deixar o link no primeiro
descrição do vídeo nesse vídeo como vou
gravar de fora e aí você vai seguir
todas as instruções que estão neste
vídeo a banda está participando entendeu
se vai estar estagnada bis que é o
primeiro link na descrição deste vídeo
aqui em baixo tá vai ter um vídeo meu
vai ter assim vou pedir pra botar a
pensão vídeo oficial está no início
o povo é que a tensão vídeo oficial e aí
quem lá tudo como é que faz
então é isso tamo junto que leva você aí
pros estados unidos comigo participar lá
é nóis e é isso aí se joga por outra
coisa [ __ ] como em agradecimento está
fazendo uma promoção para vocês
clique em curtir aqui no vídeo que já já
vai ter vida normal aí pra você está é
só um presente está bom então clique em
gostei a qui nóis tamo junto
valeu 20 milhões e roma aos 30 agora
valeu